tenemos dos números 46 más 43 cuánto
será esto como lo hemos visto en los
ejercicios pasados colocamos nuestros
números en columnas donde tenemos las
unidades y las decenas
sumamos siempre las unidades primero y
tenemos 63 es igual a 9
y pasamos ahora con las decenas
vamos a marcar una forma en la que
ustedes pueden ver esto también es una
forma en la que ustedes también pueden
ver esto es como 4 4
40-40 porque ya lo hemos visto antes lo
vamos a repasar tenemos que 46 es igual
a 40 más 6
esto es igual a 46 de la misma manera
tenemos que 43 es igual a 40 más 3
por eso podemos ver aquí el 44 es igual
a 8 ó 40 más 40 es igual a 80 porque
hacemos todo esto la intención es que
veas que al sumar las unidades en la
fila de las unidades tenemos 9 6-3 es
igual a 9 estamos hablando de 9 unos de
9 unidades pero cuando tenemos en la
siguiente columna un número este 4 lo
que realmente representa es un 40 ok no
estaremos sumando 44 realmente estaremos
sumando 40 40 por eso tenemos este
número aquí 40 más 40 es igual a 80
89 es igual a 89 que es este mismo 89
que tenemos nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo